so well I was to play with this worth of
course like showing some shower
smartphones or something like this I
don't know privileged to them anyway so
the idea of this talk is that while we
have heard about several programs and
research directions and so on to well
Slade is going to be a little bit fo
cannot to that so I'm going to talk
about a method that hopefully can be
used for our count and a specific
approximation counting problems well he
is always about invariance of course and
well it has been quite successful in in
in in other areas so empirical is so far
if you look at various kinds of
constraint set of constraint problems
well whenever whenever you have
something like this you can get a
general results I don't know if it's
Akane students a lot but general this is
what's going on so once you develop an
approach like that you start getting
some general results not before that
well there are exceptions of course and
then limitations but nervous so the hope
is that well we might be able to develop
something like this for a proximate
accounting and then well we kind of
flood the world with our brilliant
results okay so what so what this is why
actually I will mostly be talking not
about counting rules so the approximate
counting world will occur in the very
end but I want to sort of put everything
in the more in a wider half context so
what are we going to talk about well I
will be always I always fix her some
finite set of elements spins values
whatever your favorite work for that
sometimes I'll will be interested in
relations well we all know what a
relation is sometimes it's convenient to
Lucas relations a zero
functions of course like predicates for
instance well sometimes I will mean to
not relations but can probe functions
for instance if I am talking about
optimization these most cases will be
some sort of real valued functions well
if for if I'm I'm going to talk about
partition functions old then this will
be non negative or positive functions I
don't want to make so much distinction
between these two because it's exactly
the point that there is no so much
difference and so I will use the same
symbols for relations and functions
hopefully well I will confuse enough
people with that but never so so
hopefully it will be clear from the
context water we are talking about at
the moment okay so what is the general
framework constraint problems well this
is what all people here are doing in the
sense so what we have well we have some
sort of a bunch of variables well
variables take some values against beams
elements whatever you want and we have a
bunch of constraints so constraints here
can be relations well by the way this s
1 s QR just sequences of variables from
from from V so constraints can be
relations well they can be functions
whatever whatever we are talking about
well the corresponding notion of
constraint we have to use here we have
to use here well very often we will su
that all those constraints this relation
functions are belong to some fixed set
where I interested in for whatever
reason well in this case I will talk
about the instance of a CSP of gamma
some people especially in a I call this
a constraint network well we can talk
about constraint networks if you want or
constrained instances instances again
whatever okay for instance if I have
just one binary
a relation function then this is what we
have right just have a graph with all
this function impose their so we may
have any and it's an instance of an
isn't more than something like this if
we have more than one binary relation
only think about something like this
again same graph it may be labeled with
different way in a deal with different
functions relations but nevertheless the
overall concept is is more or less the
same if we go to little more general and
think about not only binary but Ellery
for area and so on relations well we may
have a hypergraph right so for instance
here i have a ternary relations relation
imposed on this or function imposed on
these three variables this one is binary
of course and so hopefully i am
consistent with indices right so our one
is generally here and it's generally
here since okay right now what what do
we want to do from such a constraint
network again it depends on the problem
we are trying to solve so that's this is
our instance if you want to solve a
decision problem which is the CSP
constraint satisfaction problem well
then we are looking for a assignment of
variables with values or something like
that an assignment that satisfies all
the constraint so this means that these
constraint a relation is satisfied so if
i take the variables take that
corresponding tuple of values well it
belongs to the relation it belongs to
the relation so in this case we are
talking about relations well if we want
to optimize samsung then ok again we are
maximizing over all possible assignment
and we must we view this constraint
network as the cost function and we want
to maximize and we want to maximize this
cost function in this case we are
summing up the values of the function of
assignment and we want to find an
assignment that that makes it as large
as possible well in sort of
combinatorial or unweighted counting
we won't remember solutions like that
satisfying solutions well if we
computing partition functions then okay
instead of salmon here we have to
multiply and then sum up so basically if
you look up about it if you look at this
safer options the only difference is
what kind of aggregation operation we
use for instance here we just use what
we use a conjunction first right all of
them must be true which we use
conjunction first and then maximization
second if we use conjunction then we
have a solution if and only if the
maximum is one and if maximum is zero
there is no solution so conjunction the
maximization so here we use summation
than maximization here we use what
conjunction and then some and then
summation and finally okay product and
some ways well that's this is the only
difference there were differences just
this aggregation operation are you only
considering the case where the set a
fixed size or you yeah well I fixed say
ain't very beginning and that size you
its weak and large we can do okay if we
fix our set of Allah what constraints
well when we have decision problem well
normal this is denoted VCS bits valid
constraints but it's since we want to
maximize the value i believe it's fair
well actually i am sort of making up the
tation entered in origin terminology as
i go well this is because it's so there
is some sort of disarray in and the more
than one people in this room actually
contributed to that disarray but anyway
well that's counting okay good so this
is basically what we want to do well the
overall problem the ultimate goal we
want to achieve he is we want to
classify the complexity of such problems
decision valued counting well
optimization problem can be classic
world
rest of optimization problem world can
be in two possible minions exact
approximate and same here exact
approximate count well what is a
proximate decision I don't know okay so
how do we do that again normally if we
want to sort of study complexity on a
large scale we want some kind of
reductions between problems with CSP
there is very clear connection with the
the most popular way of reducing
problems to to each other through
gadgets of course okay so what are
gadgets in terms of CSP well it's very
simple and very natural thing suppose I
want to express well are not so in what
Express mean means right now but suppose
I want to express some function relation
R through some other functional relation
so what can I do well suppose this one
is binary and the one I'm going to use
is also binary so what I can do well I
can construct a small graph for instance
and say well on every edge of this graph
I impose this Q then I hope that if I
only look at the terminals of the gadget
well somehow it represents our end
against the idea is that if after that I
take my constraint network plug in the
gadgets in instead of our somehow then I
can tell something meaningful about what
I get right so the hope is that if there
is such a gadget in whatever since then
CSP of our what I represent it is
reducible to CSP of Q so if look only
gadgets reductions like that well again
I don't specify right now in what sense
it's reducible it can vary from problem
to problem but the overall idea is that
all the gadgets reduction sets its look
very natural in CSP in CSP okay let's
look a sort of at more in a more
detailed way so let's look how exactly
we can use gadgets are depending on the
problems well one very general
way health or not very internet North
I'm not very interesting is just use no
auxiliary variables so let me explain
what I mean by that suppose this is my
gadget right again I use this binary
relation q and i hope to express
relation R but now what I have here must
be the relation R so everything there
are no terminals every vertex is a
terminal right so in this case our would
be six area and q is binary and in some
sense r is defined by this binary
interaction of values and so on and so
on so that would be the easiest and
simplest way I may say I can say that I
represent a new function relation as an
instance of the CSP of the constraint
problem so if I have something like that
then the reduction is really holds it
there is a reduction in all possible
means we can we can think of so that is
a very kind of straightforward and very
general well if you think about it every
time I have art I just plug in this
gadget I don't have to change anything
and I get a constraint network / q
around them are so there is no change at
all such reduction exists whatever I do
here okay so what generally if I have RL
gamma function or whatever then and
there is an instance of CSP of Delta
Delta is some other constraint language
such that using some functions relations
from Delta ill the decision case I can
expect I can express my new relation is
just disjunction of everything well that
case ESP of gamma is reducible to CSP of
Delta so if I can reduce every if I can
express that revelation from gamma this
way then I have a reduction and gamma is
easier than Delta well it in
optimization case where
I have to do something like that again
that's this is what I what we mean by
the goal of the CSP in in in the in
these cases okay so I'm just summing up
well then I get a reduction here in the
account in case okay i have to i have to
multiply i have to multiply so what am I
am supposed to do in the CSP I do here
with the gadget and I immediately get a
reduction between the problem okay very
conveniently a very convenient right so
well look let's look at snow example
suppose I take a relation and which is
represented by a gadget like this so
it's just a triangle my relation R will
be generally i have three vertices all
of them must be variables of of our and
I impose the dis equality relation on
every pair what do I get oh it's very
easy if my set a is tournament then
clear clear r is just empty I can't make
three different elements out of two
elements that well if it's more than two
it contains more than that the elements
well this is the relational different it
doesn't look like it like a big deal and
actually it is not let's say it's kind
of very weak way of reducing sense okay
so anything more complicated sorry so
another piece of terminology of random
terminology if I have some constraint
language Delta I take all functions for
relation that can be expressed by
instances while in the in the sense I I
showed on the previous slide then I say
that this set is called the whitcomb
generated by Delta and I would be
denoted like that so the idea is
whatever I have inside this week all I
can reduce to CSP of Delta whatever i
have here i can very straightforward
they are used to CSP of Delta okay
something little bit more sophisticated
sounds a little bit more complicated say
what if i look at the decision problems
and try to use some auxiliary variables
and try to use some auxiliary variables
well in the quantification case what i
have to do is this i'm trying to express
some relation using this constraint
language delta so what do i do i take an
instance of CSP of delta this constraint
network and then I quantify away some of
the variables so I say okay my
evaluation is true here if for some
values of the observables this all is
true so less then again is that there is
a reduction still between the between
the decision CSPs in this case there is
a reduction between decision csps in
this case well that was first observed
by jeevan sanders and other people well
almost 20 years ago also well it's it's
nearly it's very simple it's nearly
trivial okay again while I need the set
of all functions that can be expressed
this way I will call the clone and in
all this way well so this usually
denotes these we call what I can express
just by instances and then whatever X
reparation I used I would just put it as
a subscript okay so in this case it's
quantification again a small example so
suppose I'm trying to construct a new
ternary relation only now this way so
these are the terminals right I'm okay i
gave impose a dis equality relation so
now what happens now i have to look at
those values of x y z that can be
extended to value of this extra variable
so that all constraints are satisfied
right well unclearly what it is it's
clear what it is of course if I takes a
three element sets then this is exactly
all tuples the peoples that
are not all different so this way we can
express something more interesting
sounds more interesting now it's not
rather all different it's a complement
of all different okay what about what
about atomization well same thing very
quickly so again we can is it introduced
this notion of coal for optimization or
maximization this case well it's rather
than 25 things I have to maximize waste
our variables so I have to take the
maximal value well for all possible
extensions of my of might move my triple
again if same things happens if I if
everything can be represented like that
then there is reduction between problems
okay again small example let's take some
familiar function like very easily write
this means that it's a value of zero
zero zero one and so on of course if i
take this gadget which is called
stretching for whatever reason and say I
put this varies and curl or it on both
edges of the gadget but what do I get
well let's count so if both x and y are
zeroes right then i can put a zero one
here i have to have to compute the value
of the whole thing in both cases and
take the maxim say if this is 0 this is
0 2 i assigned 0 here this is this one
is going to be lambda this one is going
to be lambda this one if this is 1 so i
have 0 1 1 0 both equal 1 was equal one
even value is a different clearly what
have I assigned here at least one of the
two T it for at least one of the edges
for exactly one of the edges the weather
is a different and therefore in one case
for one of them fellows lambda for that
one value is 1 so what I express is
something like this what I can express
is something like this this is basically
also fairies
put fairies in function well we can
observe that the parameter here is some
way in between one and effort and lambda
so it's kind of a little milder fairies
and function so that that's what we can
achieve by either this maximization okay
what about counting exactly the same
thing the only thing that changes is
just this Sigma instead of instead of
Max and i have to multiply rather than
rather than some up so nothing changes
and again i have a reduction of course
and again of course i have a reduction
interestingly though in this case we can
go further we can go to for them if we
are dealing with relations rather than
functions we can prove a slightly
stronger result so that is very simple
it's basically trivial this is basically
trivial but you can replace Sigma here
with a quantification and that is
stronger and let us draw that allow us
to use some different tools that well
she will probably talk about later a
little bit Amit answer so there is
already non trivial but nevertheless we
would like to see that rather than other
that this is weak and this is stronger
okay again small example say let's move
let's take an implication well that's
the truth table of implication if you
remember actually I teach almost every
year this discrete math 101 and inverted
the final exam I usually trying to tie
also try to give some kind of convoluted
problem on implication basically all the
definition of implication and every time
sort of ninety-five percent fail this
test I mean well this specific problem
I'd I don't know why so that'sthat's
look very simple this is why I thought
that it's good idea to sort of reproduce
it here who knows okay let's take it
let's try to express something
you and I did it this way so I take two
terminals like this I put this little
graph and I impose implication this way
well actually Leslie gave a very similar
this example more complicated example
than that in her presentation and what
we are supposed to get is very is very
clear so if I put equal values on x and
y se 00 what happens then if both are 0
the value of this one should be 0 as
well it must be 0 but I have freedom at
this vertex right I it can be 0 it can
be one so general I have two ways of
extending x and y onto the two extra
variables so the values should be too if
these two are 0 0 for 11 it's the other
way around this one is forced to one and
and they have freedom here if all but if
the values are different then well this
must be 0 and there is no other way
around and well there is no other way
and this must be one so what I actually
get is a is a function like this if the
two things are equal I get to if they
are different i get one so this is a
fairy isn't functioning function okay so
next step well this always good we all
know that under sotis in the complexity
course will master such since but well
the real trick is to go one step further
what we are going to do we are going to
try to find some dual properties that
would sort of respect or preserve this
gadget reductions this will be
polymorphisms again i'm going to give
several versions of polymorphisms
terminology isn't isn't desirey so if
you if you want to find any connections
to other works it may be non-trivial
because while the different works
disagree on all clean terminology
notation but ok what can I do
alright so what is polymorphism well all
of everything originated in the decision
problem in decision CSP this is where
all this technology works the best works
its best and its really really
everything is very clean everything
works fine and so on it's definitely
very useful and then I will it as we go
from as we depart from decision problem
and go to optimization counting and so
on well this property will sort of
getting weekend weekend but still south
will will remain somehow okay so what
what what are we talking about suppose I
have a relation so r is a relation I say
that a function operation on the same
set possibly multi area possibly of
several variables is the polymorphism of
this relation if the following thing
happens whatever tuples I take from my
relation if I apply the function
component wise I again get a people from
the city from the relation so if i apply
functioning in any way i won't the
relation is preserved is preserved well
we may think of it as some kind of high
degree or high order symmetry of the
relation right so this polymorphisms
sort of moves the relation around but
nevertheless it is preserved well for
the set of all polymorphisms of a single
relation or a bunch of relations i will
write pull out pull of our poll of gamma
okay what is good about them i will give
a couple of examples of polymorphisms in
the next slide but just let's finish
with this kind of more general stuff
what is known about it what is known is
that polymorphism describe precisely
gadget reductions in decision CSPs just
hundred percent very very exact so if i
can express our then this is because our
has all the polymorphisms of gamma well
it may have more
but it definitely has all the
polymorphisms of gamma so in some sense
our gadgets what I can get using gadgets
is captured by polymorphisms hundred
percent very very exactly very exactly
okay well this means that if I have some
inclusion between pollen or polymorphism
of constraint languages then i also have
a reduction between the csps well it
should be Z right so if this one has
more polymorphisms than gamma this means
that it's sort of smaller right it has
no symmetries so this one is bigger this
one is smaller and so yes ESP of Delta
is reducible this way okay same is true
for counting problems for exact count
and unweighted to be more precise okay
couple of examples say I take a relation
like that just three pairs 0 1 1 to 20
my base set it has three elements and my
function is this X minus y plus Z where
plus or minus R modulo 3 a module three
so I'm claiming that F is a polymorphism
far why is that oh ok what did what am I
supposed to do it I'm supposed to take
some pears from here apply the function
component wise and check what I get
right for instance I take all the three
pair say in this order well it may
depend on the order in which i take them
well let's count so 0 minus 2 plus 1 I
think it's won 1-0 plus 2 of course it's
0 2 0 it's there ok I have to take some
other combination for instance i take
0120 they don't have to be different
right so i can take 0 1 again 0 minus 2
plus 0 is 1 1 minus zero plus one is two
ok and i have to do all all such the
checks for all possible selection of
theirs Oh
well oh by the way why this is true it's
because this is a cassette of a subspace
of the two dimensional linear space so
actually this function exactly preserves
such cassettes that's a non-trivial fact
but there's less well it's easier of a
lot to you so sometimes polymorphisms
capture kind of nice properties of tough
relations okay well some other property
for instance if I have a majority
operation which means that whatever XY x
and y are if I uh whoa okay it that's
out like majority right so it takes the
majority of its valence in this case if
I have a relation invariant okay you
should preserve some if this is the
polymorphism of simulation a terminology
then this relation is basically defined
by its binary projections so a tipple
belongs to the relation if every pair of
entries belong to the career to the
corresponding projection of our so in
some sense in this case our can be
represented as a single instance without
any quantification from binary relations
so this can capture this property as
well polymorphisms can capture this
property as well okay some results are
the dichotomy conjecture for the CSP
will roughly speaking CSP is porn on
I'll try and solve both even though
leave gana has a non-trivial
polymorphism otherwise it's NP complete
well so one of the dichotomy a
conjectures well it's proven many in
many particular in many special cases
it's still open in the hood in general
but well Jeannie was saying that in
order to have a polar time algorithm
something beautiful has to happen well I
have a precise definition of beauty for
you polymorphism is beautiful
what's that so same happens for exact
count well I believe she will be talking
about exact count in but well he will
probably represent is in a different way
but still the exact count in dichotomy
cat serum in this case can also be
captured by polymorphisms it works just
nicely in this case what's a
what I mean it can be yes yes it can
well I mean I don't know how but it can
so there is a property of these things
that captures exactly that but we just
don't know the property at least we
cannot express it unique in eat it in a
concise way okay what about optimization
well Frampton ization things a little
bit more difficult of course so let's
first talk about the exact optimization
a morphism for optimization well there
are several versions but let's start
with the simple one well actually
properties like this will will will show
up for approximate counting as well so
we better cover that to some extent the
simplest one is multi morphism also
multi morphism already sort of suggests
that it's not very simple well again I
have the set I take some operations in
some operations on a then I say that
this collection of operations is a multi
morphism of some function are on the
same set if for for any collection of
well if this one is K area then this
should be k tuples as well the following
condition holds if I take the sum of
values of my function all these things
separate and then I apply all the
separations to all these things
component wise and then compute our that
I have to have some I have to get
something small I have to get something
small well that is kind of not very easy
to understand what it means exactly but
well the lady is after we apply this
multi morphism we get something worse
not better right so will prefer this not
this well there are very nice very fine
examples of multimode reasons for
instance sub modularity if my set is a
01
as and one I take the conjunction as
empty i take this junction then my
condition well complete there are forms
into something like that and this is
exactly the sub modularity condition as
one of the it's extremely well studied
and this is one of the few no reason
reason to be 40 ization problem to be
solved in polynomial time so that is a
very well-known condition and it's very
important ask your question yes what's
what do you mean by non-trivial when you
talk about polymer material ok so
official at real bond is so called
projection or dictator it's a fun it's
an operation that always takes the value
of one of you of the same one of its
arguments say f of XY that always equals
y that is a tree build one so i can
imagine like taking my decision problem
doubling it all right like this training
two copies of this is the same decision
problem and I thinking about the
polymorphism thats wats variables no no
well the polymer physics on values not
variables on values always talking about
a which is the set of values
yeah well it's it's it's the same it's
the same idea so some transformations of
the 000 of the set of values I feel like
I can always create something with sort
of a non-trivial looking multi-port
polymorphism but then i just bought out
by and i get back to the original thing
by just creating copies and then like
permuting them all copies don't don't
help copies don't tell you ok actually
its complexity at all right but it
produces some system that's like it has
ok so let's go back for instance well to
my result like this one for instance so
suppose I have this polymorphism this
means that whatever relation you have it
has to be expressible by a system of
linear equations so the claim well the
precise claim in this case would be if i
have this polymorphism your CSP is just
sold well by girls in elimination so
that's that's how it works more or less
so every week every polymorphism give
you some kind of non-trivial property of
relation that you can use to solve your
problem quickly that's the idea well yes
what is it what what this property is
this is exactly the problem so how we
can use that property to construct a
polynomial time algorithm that's the
that's exactly the problem that
everybody is trying to sue
okay so multi more pheasants or sub
modularity well we can generalize that
so that's that's not all it doesn't
captures exactly the complexity of off
of up of a optimization CSP so we can go
a little bit further and construct
things are slightly more general so
instead of marking morphisms we can use
fractional polymorphisms or is it the
current official till fractional
polymorphisms well it was two days ago
so that should be so what what do we do
we can fix this base set like the set of
spins and consider all operations se que
era operations on this set its beak if
you count how many operations there I
it's the number it's the size of a to
the power of size of a to the power of K
so this set is big this set is big so
all such operations okay then I take a
probability distribution on the same
electron this set so it's a big step i
take a distribution on this set so mu i
will call this distribution a fractional
polymorphism of a function say a real
valued function well it sounds and
similar to those multi morph is immense
the expectation which is a problem Larry
fired way of of of representing a a
weighted sum of course should be less
than the average of just summing up the
values of the function so if you compare
with Matthew Morrison it just means that
my distribution is zero everywhere
except for those n 1 and so on for
instance for sub module are four sub
modularity k equals 2 i'm talking about
binary functions i assign in my
distribution assign probability one-half
to conjunction disjunction and 0 to
everything else and well this is what i
get from my from the inequality
from the inner court so what is good
about that what is good about that okay
first of all again if I take if I take
the set of all such fractional
polymorphisms then it describes exactly
precisely the gadget reductions between
optimization problems first of all
described precisely as a gadget
reductions between optimization problems
and we can use it again this thing is so
low and polynomial time if and don't
leave there is a non-trivial also
non-trivial in this case is slightly
different I don't want to go into
details and announcing your fractional
polymorphisms otherwise it's hard
otherwise it's hard don't people
involved so again the same thing
non-trivial problem washes means a good
algorithm now such polymorphism no
algorithm what about approximation
approximately again optimization but now
approximate case approximation case it's
very similar so again well I don't
expect sort of everybody internalized
the stills but so nervous so it's kind
of very similar again I take a
distribution over all possible
operations on the set a and so on and so
on but now I have one more parameter
alpha and I am talking about Alf
approximation polymorphisms well if you
compare the inequalities on the previous
slide slide and this one there are
basically two differences first the
sulfur here and the sign is different
it's the other way around instead we're
out well clearly somehow go together
again I don't want to go into details of
that but the main thing about this is
that using these well we can classify
all the the complexity of all
optimization approximate complexity for
optimization problems for instance if or
a constraint length ever let alpha gamma
is the greatest commit constant such
that there is a non-trivial in yet
another sense I'll forget my
approximation polymorphism then well
here we have to make an assumption more
precisely the unique games conjecture
alpha gamma is the approximation
threshold for for the CSP meaning that
there is an algorithm that approximates
it with this well but so there is no
allegation that approximates it better
that approximated but the interesting
thing about about this is that okay the
solution algorithm here is seven
different program it's semi definite
programming what happens is that such
polymorphism actually gives you around
in skin for this SDP so in a sense in
this case polymorphism is the algorithm
so previously we have okay well we can
exploit this property in this way or
that way but here everything is very
simple polymorphism is their algorithm
is there okay okay so finally
approximate counting I still have a few
minutes talk about approximate counting
so first of all again let's follow the
same scheme and see how far we can go
with that combs well it's counting so we
can use the same Sigma clone so with
summation is loud but since we can
approximate we can also use limits we
can also use lube it's what it means
this means that if I have a sequence of
functions that all below to that clone
Sigma then I can take the limit of those
functions right pointwise limit of those
functions and well i can approximate
well enough to simulate problems with
this with this
our simulate problems with this are so
this will be my omega clothes this will
be my Omega clothes ok what I know what
we know again well it's not that
difficult to show that if I have a gamma
in this Omega call that the count in CSP
is AP reducible to accountancy SP 0
Delta County can we find any morphisms
morphisms in any sense well actually yes
we can the problem how good they are how
good they are so if any pay is it
anymore feels for that well first of all
a simple observation for any constraint
length which if I think of all the
irrational valued functions there is a
constraint language of relations well
possible on a different set such that
CSP of gamma count in CSP of gamma is
equivalent where grew up near means
parsimonious reduction so it just the
answer is the same to the two of this
CSP of this bunch of relations so in a
sense functions are not so important in
this sort of very general sense also in
the kind of local sense they might be
very important but nevertheless what
does it mean this means that actually we
can forget about functions and use our
nice convenient relations and try to do
something with relations what can we do
with relations well what can we do with
relations oh well we can't come up with
a notion of a weaker even weaker
polymorphisms than before we can talk
about partial operations now and I say
that such a declaration is a partial
polymorphism well if for a nature choice
of tuples from our if I apply my
function of Y operation to that it
either belongs to R or doesn't exist
it's partial operation so it may not
exist at all it may not exist at all
what is good about that again people
means partial polymorphisms of
relational or constraint language and
where
of these special polymorphisms exactly
describe we close we come so yes the
complexity of anything like this is can
be characterized by a property of
partial polymorphisms fine is it helpful
well of course not well that is a very
difficult this is a very complicated
object so well we replaced one
complicated object with another
complicated object and basically it says
that CSP of relations is as difficult as
computing partition functions than
saying that partition functions are as
easy as counting CSPs of off relations
okay okay we do something better than
that so can we do better can we come up
with some sort of morphisms for these
things well not alone yet it's kind of
strangely difficult somehow but ok we
can look at options and actually at
every time we look at some option we get
something new so we learn something
about account about the complexity of
counting problems so for instance if we
use one of the existent types of
morphisms well for instance I don't know
something like sub modularity well
suppose I have a function it should be
our ok notation tation oh ok so suppose
I have a function i say its sub modular
if i have something like like this which
basically means if i take the log III
can i say it's logging some super
modular look super module if i take the
logarithm of both i basically have the
supermajority condition alright so it
will be log of F plus log of F less than
log of F plus log of F ok it's a well
for instance terrorism keys and Ellison
function an entire Isaac is not an
allison function actually David
yesterday mentioned these things several
times
it's a it's an Omega clone it's useful
it's closed down the reductions so fine
well the problem is it's not clear if
the same if the same holds for other
multi morphisms can it replace LSN with
any other condition sometimes yes
sometimes we don't know sometimes not
probably so that's unclear but rather
less even though well it it can be
generalized apparently well we can learn
something for instance that eventually
led to this conservative account in CSP
result well I will say that constraint
which is conservative again just
following David from yesterday's
presentation is concerned if you eat if
it contains all unary functions if it
contains all unary functions then well
use all that lsm we can have a almost
complete complexity classification of
these languages of conservative
constraint languages well i believe
about twenty percent of people in this
room way involved one way or another in
that anyway so we don't sound it done
something useful what else can we do we
can look at the tria transform of our
function that might be useful so that's
a very brief definition of free a
coefficient again okay I don't want to
sort of to explain more with that just
nice transformation and as we know very
useful for instance we can take the set
of functions for which all the Fourier
coefficients are non-negative and it's a
property of rear coefficient well then
it's again it's a nice Omega clone it's
closed under all the gadget reductions
okay can we get something interesting
with that yes we can for instance there
are some interesting constraint
languages that are related to this PF
and lsm that's roughly water somebody
asked Dave I think yesterday if there is
a life below lsm yes their reason
this some science of this life are come
exactly from from this from this clone
so there isn't there there are since
then what else well maybe we do all
wrong and maybe we shouldn't be sort of
perceiving such a strong reduction such
strong reductions maybe we have to be
happy with something easier well for
instance let's relax the clones operator
right look at this just the basic very
basic we clone this is in a sense what
cassatt ragavendra used with his
approximation algorithm proxima shin
polymorphisms okay so if we follow that
that reach and take profit as a role
model what we can do well we have to
sort of elevated one level up we can
talk about vogue approximation
polymorphisms or function it should be
are right it should be are well I say
it's log approximation if it is a one
approximation polymorphism of the
logarithm again it behaves nicely with
this one with this week clone well
everything behaves nicely with the
weaker and in a sense it worked for
Prasad maybe it works here so there are
other options as well as it again but
the overall idea is that well we need
some find some beauty right so that we
can or some concept of beauty so that we
can do this advanced in this
classification program well clearly
gadgets reactions are not everything
well i haven't mentioned whole problem
here at all and this is because well it
can we use more gadgets reductions say
holographic reductions are not budget
reductions and so well it's not quite
clear if if it if they fit into this
framework at all maybe maybe not that i
don't know okay
oh alright that's basically what I
already set okay thank you question is
shall convincingly that you can't reduce
any kind of the problem to studying
polymorphisms you think it's always a
useful thing to do lord i'm assuming
always nothing's not always what i'm
saying if people do reductions anything
why do they need to know that they're
doing polymorphism well Michael and it's
always useful for CSP for other problems
maybe less so okay so you cannot see any
parallels or say Colin problems or
anything like that well that's what I
said I have no idea if it fits in any
way in this from framework I mean is
that because you haven't thought about
it
I don't know well I haven't thought
about it so I don't know ok any other
longer in the Omega a clone there's a
limit operation right and any comment on
the comments fader if it converge but
it's too slow that I guess still not
good for it abductions yes it has to be
one of those ours has to be
representable by sort of polynomial size
right that's remote
ok again